the Joe Rogan experience there's there's
some great good to exposing these things
but in doing so the overzealous approach
of accusing all men of being potential
rapists isn't it just just an
overreaction and won't it balance itself
out do you or do you think that it's
more complicated than that it's gonna
it's gonna backfire yes it looks like a
power grab but won't the backfiring
bounce itself out I mean people
reasonable people like you or myself or
we're always gonna recognize the
difference that there are monsters yes
right and we're not gonna deny monsters
because someone goes too far in the
accused Garrison Keillor of being a
monster when we know that that's not
true it doesn't make sense the story
doesn't make sense so because most
people who I've talked to about the
garrison keillor story which he was
consoling a woman and he touched her
back and then she pulled back and he
apologized and I didn't mean to do that
and then he sent her an email apologized
she said no big deal don't worry about
it they were good for a while and then
years later when all this meat to things
she just decides I remember something
that was wrong and let's let's take this
guy down like what just didn't make any
sense that first of all well let's leave
it alone didn't make any sense but
where's garrison keillor now right we're
like yeah he hasn't been resurrected he
hasn't been resurrected they took his
shows off the air it doesn't make you
decide you know whether or not you like
him as an artist or creator just like
they actually destroyed not just him but
his legacy for a hug for something that
at the time both parties agreed was no
big deal yeah I saw her stand it I go
it's completely unacceptable and it's
the death of justice well was that just
getting caught up in the hysteria of
just like trying to find tar there's one
put that fire out immediately so we have
a couple of problems and one of the
problems is that the folks who are
advancing this movement and the other
parallel I wish they hadn't taken the
term social justice because we need a
replacement term for that that is not
overzealous but
those movements have engaged in a kind
of naive conclusion making that makes
them inevitably hijack they get
inevitably hijacked by bad actors so if
you you are essentially looking at a
situation if you say we must believe all
victims that's like putting out a neon
sign for bad actors that wish to utilize
this structure right so and there will
be bad actors yes every population male
is a population female as a population
they're monstrous males who have been
behaving predatory there will be women
who will take advantage of this and
accuse people without reason I mean we I
don't know whether the numbers are
robust or not that I have heard numbers
that somewhere between 1% to 4% of the
population are sociopathic if you set up
a system in which we are obligated to
believe every victim then those people
will come out of the woodwork and they
will use this to level their enemies and
so at the very least what that tells you
is rule number one you cannot make the
rule you must believe all victims or you
will have lots of people piling into the
category of victim that don't deserve to
be there and who is hurt most by that
not only the people who are going to be
sabotaged by bad actors but the people
who have suffered the worst cases of you
know rape they are effectively having
the terrible things that have happened
to them deluded by stories that are
either fictional or minor that are being
lumped in so it's were their
victimization of them it is it's a
transfer of well-being from the people
who have been most harmed to people who
have been less harmed or are cynically
using these structures so if the idea of
me - of the reckoning that has finally
come for these really terrible guys who
were getting away with all of this
office
if that is close to your heart then what
you should want is a set of rules that
is careful enough and robust enough that
we can keep holding those kinds of
people to account what will happen if we
don't do that and I promise you this
from a game theoretic perspective if we
decide you must believe all victims and
all transgressions are equally bad we're
gonna turn the thing to 11 for
everything now that happened with you
but how did that happen if you're if
you're cynical
it's the dine of nuance in part yeah it
is it is a the death of nuance because
if you're wielding this thing as a
weapon right if you what you want to do
is turn the tables on all men if you
want to take power and say you listen
well this is a frightening weapon so in
order to make that weapon maximally
dangerous you you equate your with
catcall yeah you say it's all one
there's nothing a woman could ever do
that would increase her likelihood of
facing any of this and you know we
should cover that in a second because
that's one of these it's another one of
these booby traps where you can very
easily say the wrong thing and suddenly
you're on the defensive even though what
you've said is very rational but also it
denies the reality of what male-female
relationships look like when they're at
all healthy there's going to be risk
there is risk as you get to know people
and I don't you know we're just meeting
say instead of having met in high school
so many years ago I don't know if I like
you yet you don't know if you like me
yet we're going to take some chances and
maybe you're gonna say something wrong
and I'm not gonna be thrilled with it
are you at fault
do I do I blame you do I cry harassment
because you said something that didn't
quite fall right on my ears or did it
sound right and I kind of liked you
anyway and so I got stands fine you know
we're good well it really depends you
know how how I receive that depends a
lot on how I feel about you otherwise
you could say exactly the same words and
you know you could say it and someone
else could say it and from that guy I
might feel like I kind of wish
hadn't said that but that has to mean
that that isn't big deep problem that he
said it because we're engaged something
we're trying to discover do we like each
other are we into each other like what's
going on here
so the process of discovery is going to
involve mistake and risk and then even
some sort of it's it's game playing you
know you're involved in the social game
and what you're trying to figure out who
each other are and after-the-fact saying
that guys kind of gross so the thing
that he said was harassment sorry no not
not acceptable it's changing the rules
of the game based on whether or not you
like the particular individual and
that's not a legit move so we've got to
be super careful here
yeah one thing that is true is we are
facing a landscape in which we are
I think effectively rewriting the rules
of male-female interaction in order to
make sex with strangers perfectly safe
now sex with strangers can't be
perfectly safe in a world in which
you're dealing with let's say it's 1%
sociopaths you can't make a world in
which it's safe to take a sociopath home
and have sex with them right that that's
not going to happen
but in order to try to make it safe
we're going to turn up all of these
protections so for example we've got the
issue of affirmative consent now
affirmative consent is a great failsafe
in a circumstance where you are dealing
with a stranger it seems like it would
be absolutely essential because the
danger of a miscommunication is so great
that you have to be perfectly explicit
and there can be there's no room for any
coyness or subtlety about it in other
words it has to effectively be
transactional but ah no courtship that's
going to make it into history books or
literature is going to involve
affirmative consent at every stage you
undo it yes
how about now yeah did years remember
that video that they released there was
a video that boy I don't remember who
did it but is essentially showing how
consent can be sexy and so it shows this
millennial couple making out and like
every few seconds the guy has to ask the
girl if it's okay if he kisses her if
it's is it okay if I touch you here is
it okay if I take your shirt off and she
says not yet and then they keep going
and going and going and then the girls
asking the guy which is hilarious is it
okay if I do this like what because this
is imaginary
exactly exactly it's not symmetric just
the Posterous right well that was also
an issue with they've sort of abandon
this but a few years ago there was this
thing where if you had sex with someone
and alcohol was involved you raped them
because they could not consent but I'm
like well that means I've been raped a
lot of times that's ridiculous
like it did but it never worked that way
it does if you want symmetry you would
have to say that if the man has consumed
alcohol and the woman hasn't then the
woman is raping the man well I don't
want to freak you out but Heather and I
have been assuming each other's consent
for thirty years I mean we have inferred
it from cues that were not verbal you
guys didn't discuss what about really
writing things down do you have a chalk
border no I mean and the thing is the
only thing safe from being arrested for
this release we've both done it no it's
like right you're both criminals right
yeah but this this these changing these
shifting of the rules it so it seems
like it's almost like you were talking
about game theory it does it really does
seem like a type of game it is life but
it is a thing where people are looking
to call people out you're you're looking
to score you're looking to like score
yours finding someone who's done
something inappropriate or finding
someone who has done something that used
to be appropriate but it's no longer and
we're looking to establish this new
parameter and this new way of existing
and that there's this it takes on this
competition element which I'm very
familiar with I understand competition
so I said when I see it clearly and I
see like Team B
Avia I'm like more I see what's going on
here this is not rational thinking this
is someone who's trying to score points
you're trying to get one on the board
yes it's absolutely competitive and it's
really competitive at the moment it
looks like sort of within women and it's
going to destroy it's actively making
male-female relationships impossible to
navigate but I don't understand it it's
for as a man I get the motivation I
think that women overwhelmingly have
been victimized as opposed to like men
being victimized by women in that regard
in terms of being sexually harassed it's
not even close
I mean is is one of the most unbalanced
things in our culture ever completely
right but in our culture right this is
what we're talking right what do we want
out of this now safety now that it's but
right do you want a hundred percent
safety right do you want to maximize
safety at the cost of well we have to
kill sociopaths so I want to do that
yeah the point is if you want if you
want absolute safety I mean we're
getting to the point where this is just
robbing okay if the point of this is to
make sex safe because it's pleasurable
this is gonna Rob all of the pleasure
from sex I mean it's it's getting to the
point where you'd be crazy to have sex
without witnesses you know what I'm
saying yeah but but anyway the point is
now that the stuff is on the table right
now that we've we know that there are
monsters we know that there are economic
forces that actually protect these
monsters which frankly is a big part of
this story hmm right is that the
economic structure of something like
Hollywood causes this to continue with
it being effectively an open secret that
these people are abusing women and then
silencing them and contractually
obligated them not to do anything about
it that that that cancer on the social
system is now open for discussion and we
all of us decent folk know that we have
to get rid of it if you get rid of it
though on false pretenses I promise you
the very same game theory that caused it
to happen in the first place will cause
it to re-emerge the only the reason it
will be it's harder to address the next
time
[Applause]